[Music]
let's shift let's talk about the scary
right are you ready I tried to do this
bad we did the happy stuff yes we're
going to plunge look you know Dave when
I began to research this thing I
probably ended up reading about 200
books on this topic why the end and and
I'm a happy guy I like happy things are
like technology I'm an optimistic guy
but this really put me in a dark place
digging through this history from from
Hegel essentially up to Julius Caesar
Avila and the and the post-war Nazi
movement and realizing that there is an
intellectual strain that stretched over
all of these years okay so let let
silver two hundred years yeah so let's
go back 200 years when you talk about
right-wing collectivism yep because I
think most of my audience now
understands what left-wing collectivism
is because that's what we've got right
now very in a very strong way talk to me
about right-wing collectivism okay David
I gotta tell you a story
I love Luda von Mises I think he was a
genius right and I thought I'd read all
of his works but and there was a
transcript of a lecture he gave in 1956
at the San Francisco Public Library and
he had about three sentences in there
that just knocked me over and I couldn't
believe it it because they explained so
much he says something like this and
he's speaking casually right he says
Hegel ruined German philosophy for a
century
his original followers became believed
that all of history would end in the
Prussian state and the Prussian Church
having all power and the end of
individualism they became the right he
galleons that became the Nazis his the
dissidents of this of the right had
galleons became the left to galleons
they wanted a universal transformation
of humanity and a historical drive to to
something other than the commercial
society they became the Marxist and and
the communists and he said that that's
it's the left right he galleon ISM and
that explains pretty much all the
political history and I
that I thought no that explains more
than practically any other book I've
ever read and so I began to begin to
explore this I understood the left to
Gallienus I understood Marxism I mean
those were those were our professors
right and they're annoying but what I
did not understand was the right
Hegelian ISM and what that what that
tradition looks like is that the throne
and altar this this historic sister you
that the nation should constitute its
own unit of profound integrity that that
that is more important than the
individual and that commercial society
was too chaotic that it that that it was
leading us giving us the wrong kind of
progress that it was flattening out the
hierarchies that we need to have an
orderly life right this is this is the
right hey Gillian pitch that ultimately
by mid 20th century becomes this very
dangerous dangerous movement in Europe
you know it became catastrophic but it
gradually emerged from all the way from
from Hegel because this is at the the
end of the endless seemingly endless
franco-prussian war there's this battle
at the Battle of Jena that that Germany
lost and the explanation for that was
that it was a temporary setback that
history was going to determine that
Germany would rise just despite despite
the choices of individuals history's got
its wind it's like meta-narrative that
that that was going to override
everything Hegel himself was a
theologian by the way and so and so this
this view began to kind of spread
throughout German academia and it was it
ended up being imported to the United
States through through circuitous means
but one of the great theorists of the of
the 1840s who and 1850s who brought the
suit to the nine states of Frederick
list who was one of the first economists
to repudiate the free trade tradition of
the Smith Ian Manchester ides and now
was celebrating the nation as a unit as
productive power and and believed in
tariff walls which was strange and a
viridis book but and that had a huge
influence of American trade policies
actually the late 19th century and and
it began to flow out from there so
Thomas Carlyle and and and Britain now
begins to celebrate the great man theory
of history and really were nothing
without Napoleon without without
gigantic figures that we can worship
admire and and and our individuality
should be subsumed within them they act
for us their godlike you know and and
and it was Thomas Carlyle who first
coined the phrase quote coined the
phrase to describe acute economics as
being the dismal science and the reason
he said that is that every economist he
knew imagined a world without slavery
and he said you can't have a world South
slavery that's that's a dreadful world
without slaves you don't have masters
right and we need a world with masters
and slaves so we can we can have a
vision of hierarchy and greatness
without that we don't have greatness so
you begin to see this building of this
intellectual apparatus that was not left
to galleon there wasn't Marxist he was
actually anti-marxist another strange
way but as an alternative form of
collectivism it began with a kind of a
historicism and a celebration of
nationalism of the German state it began
to grow with this there's this
alternative theory of trade that we
should we should build up tariff walls
and Carlyle with his with his great man
theory of history and then and then
Ruskin and and Britain with his hatred
of commercial society because they
believe that somehow Commerce was
ruining quality and culture and was
giving us mass production about we all
need to be really doing this is is
living in guilds and and making our own
stuff you know because we're gonna
destroy English life and English country
life and so so a full-scale reactionary
trend on the right began to develop and
we're always a racial element
so that's what's interesting I'm so glad
you asked that because it comes about
first of all through through nationalism
now in the in the early 1820s and 1830s
this the celebration of nationalism now
you have to ask yourself what is a
nation but what do we mean when we say
nation and and I'm taking this a lot of
this from from an S I gave it given to
1882 by Ernst ran in a great French
historian looking back at the rise of
nationalism said there's only five ways
you can consider nationalism we consider
the geographic definition so we're just
living the space there's a dynastic
element we can all trace our lineage
back to the great founders of our our
nation there's a language theory of
nationalism we all speak the same
language there's a religious theory of
nationalism we all worship God and a
precise assembly I believe in
transubstantiation do you believe in
consubstantiation we can't be part of a
nation in that case right and then
finally and probably most insidiously
there was a racial the ratio of you and
that came along and essentially the
1860s and 1870s with a misapplication of
Darwinian theory and scientific racism
came along and that swept through
academia particularly in the United
States like nothing you've ever seen it
was absolutely astonishing how much
racism with orthodoxy in American
academia in the 1890s from the very
first monograph published by the
American Economic Association by a game
I think his name is Andre Hoffman was
called race traits of the American Negro
and the first chapter dress goes all-in
you know it's it's it's the the horror
of the black people they don't have the
right values they can't can't save money
that is terrible shiftless and and lazy
and ghastly and uncivilized Abel and now
chapter 2 the Jews you know these people
I don't know what they've got this
crazed out of control commercial ethics
they can't stop hoarding money they
really went for it yeah and then chapter
3 is the slauson's and so on and so the
American
Association you know and then and there
was essentially no what do you think was
happening in the world there that it was
taking Italian what was happening baby
let's a fair had transformed society so
dramatically that the the intellectuals
felt that they had lost control now you
might think that when the world becomes
massively prosperous and we suddenly
have cities rising up and we've got
steel that's transversing large bodies
of water and we're developing the
telephone and indoor electricity and and
people are living longer lives and and
so much wealth is being created that
everybody was data to say Hawaii we've
found the answers but the gatekeepers
who had controlled everything for so
long so that's so interesting because of
revolt this is sort of what it feels
like now to me the gatekeepers we've had
so much success
there's someone there's so many reasons
right now to understand how great
everything is that book right there by
Steven Pinker and light mr. right book
is is all about how great things are and
has a very probably we are there is less
violence now in all sorts of the revolt
you always have to be on the gamekeepers
aren't having you know not in the
narrative intellectuals are what
regional classic calls the Clara Sea
right so it's it's the the high-end
intellectuals it's the power elite
bureaucrats and and the public the the
permanent people keepers of our civic
culture you know it's it's the political
class and so this is sort of what my
audience that maybe not families this is
sort of what the New York Times is sort
of right like yeah maybe I shouldn't
have said it so obviously but like
that's kind of what it is like that
class a ruling class yeah the ruling
class and and they were in full-scale
revolt oh they did not like what was
happening to the world in the 1880s and
90s because of the loss of control and
so the the scientific racism came along
to add to the celebration of
dictatorship and the and and
protectionism and the new nationalism to
add a very insidious element which
culminated in eugenics ideology and
that's when it gets very strange and
this is where this is where they're
reading gets very difficult because now
you're reading all the way into your the
the the 1910s
the works of Oswald Spengler you know
the the right he galleon German theorist
and enraptured every American here
they're all reading his book oh my god
the decline of the West we better
reconstitute ourselves as a tribe or
we're gonna be eaten alive by but
there's a strain of that that's still
going on right now you know there's
nothing new you like and and you know
the this this very funny book called the
passing of the great race by Madison
grant that was on every coffee table and
the late nineteenth and early 1920s you
know was was forecasting doom for the
white race you know and he was he was a
fascinating figure because you know of
course I British because as it everybody
did everybody the Great Gatsby makes a
passing reference to it it was that
popular it was that popular and I tell
you there's not a single outright racist
alive today who hasn't is not repeating
those cliches that were written by
Madison grant it's all pseudoscience is
all just nonsense and it's just
ridiculous embarrassing but but it keeps
being resurrected but here's what's
interesting
he was a thoroughgoing Darwinian because
she recall that Darwin had two great
books Origin of Species the other was
called The Descent of Man and The
Descent of Man had the very unfortunate
paragraph in there where he gret regrets
the invention of mass disease killing
cures essentially it's like if we keep
curing people and we keep feeding
inferior people and and curing disease
then then our genetic stocks gonna go
down and down you know so so they're all
kind of playing off this little passage
the Madison grant was was not an unusual
by American acts to academic standards
at all they oh they this is Orthodox in
the 1810 to 1920s what made Madison
grant interesting you can look up his
Wikipedia entry right now if you look it
up it'll it'll celebrate him as the as
the father of the National Park Service
well in the course of my research I
wanted to know what is the connection
between Madison's grants hardcore
eugenics based racism and his
environmentalism hmm what is the
relationship there and it's not just to
people usually people have haven't
figured out in their own heads I went
through and read some of his works on
him on the environment it turns out that
he had a master race theory of nature
and he went to the California Redwoods
and he looked at these glorious mighty
trees and he was horrified to see they
were being cut down for for making
coffee tables and boats and things like
that he thought it was dis genic to
nature
so he wanted the master race but
California ed woods too to be protected
and that's that so that's why he started
the National Park Service and now the
left Harrelson is as this great as a
great visionary environmentalist but
actually he was like a tree Nazi I don't
know how you want to call it green ice
very creepy stuff we don't have enough
Nazi labels being thrown around now
we're gonna have tree not you ensure
that order he was nuts but you know you
could just march through the history and
it gets worse and worse and then to me
Dave it all it all culminates in the
works of Karl Schmitt from the from the
late 1930s and is in his amazing book
called the concept of the political and
if you'll give me just one quick second
to explain this because because you as a
liberal I would need to read this book
because it's the most passionate I would
say an even competent attack under Bill
ISM written in the 20th century now Carl
Schmitt that's a jurist a brilliant man
and a philosopher and a hardcore Nazi
okay he wasn't tried at Nuremberg he
escaped I'm merely an intellectual ok
sure his book concept of the political
says what's wrong with liberalism I tell
you it's dull
nothing happens nothing dramatic there's
nothing just requires no courage
whatsoever liberalism is a life in which
we all benefit from each other's
presence we all just trade with each
other what kind of life is that where we
all just are kind of the same and like
each other and hope backyard barbecues
and baseball games and and just get
richer and live longer lives and send
our kid to college this is terrible
we need to live big dramatic mighty bold
courageous transformative lives and live
in times that that that that that are
shocking that are amazing that make our
lives worth living that requires above
all else
politics liberalism imagines a world
without politics that's a terrifying
world what we need is a world of
politics and and he continues to lay it
out chapter by chapter why we have to
destroy liberalism and celebrate the
concept of the political and for him
that means having friends and having
enemies defeating your enemies and
rallying around your friends now who are
your friends and who your enemies and
Carl Schmitt says at some level it
doesn't matter what matters is that they
exist and then the state the powerful
men will choose them for us they will
decide who our friends and our enemies
are now let's be clear what we mean by
enemy I just don't mean something you
don't like I mean the willingness to
kill there has to be the presence of
real bloodshed in your time for you to
have a sufficiently prescient sense of
any meanness so that you'll feel the
intense desire to rally around your
friend for your friends and experience
that that the the awesomeness that only
comes with belonging to a group so so he
says so here the end feeling there is
that you can't achieve what what the
real purpose of a human is that's right
that you can't experience whatever the
the highs of belongingness essentially
and and the life of drama the a big
important life without being part of a
kind of a group on the move the
slaughtering and enemies and so we have
to have the presence of a bloodshed so
it really is the opposite of live in let
live it is it so through through through
bloodshed comes life and without without
bloodshed and death and violence and
politics then you're just gonna live at
an irrelevant life and we can't have
that so he was in many ways the
philosophical architect of the Holocaust
again not a leftist not a Marxist
although he dabbled in a you find this a
little from a lot of these right
collectivists the right and elegance
that they dabbled guys
Vernor son Bart writers once a communist
have later became a Nazi Carl Schmitt
dabbled and and leftism and then went
full right and it was in many ways the
culmination of the writer galleon
ideology and the increment so it's it's
a book worth reading and contemplating
and I would say to anybody who rejects
liberalism you know be honest about
where you're going with this this is the
opposite of liberalism and celebration
of death in the works of Karl Schmitt
very powerful thinker highly regarded
even today worth reading and worth
reflecting on what kind of world you
want to live in you want to live in at
peace with others what do you want to
slaughter your friends a slaughter your
enemies and rally with your friends so
move me from that point 1930s into of
course obviously into Nazi Germany and
so actually well yeah and and you know
my book really does end in nineteen
fifty and not necessarily didn't have to
but I started to get really queasy about
what happened after World War two a lot
of the writing Elian movement went
underground you know and and became a
kind of a quiet neo-nazi movement that
never really had access to social media
they were clear they weren't in academia
obviously and but the ideology never
entirely went away and and it was just
lying in wait wait waiting for the
failure of the left and for the
resentment of the population against the
left to rise up and receive who get it a
fevered enough pitch that it would it
would then come on full force and that's
really what's happening in Europe Russia
United States it's an alternative form
of collectivism it's got a different
flavor a different orientation a
different kind of resentments but it
still drags in this gigantic history of
writing gillion ideology the celebration
of the dick great man dictated the
protectionism the anti-immigration the
nativism the nationalism that could take
any one of five forms including the
racism what do you make about how now
and it's obviously largely because of
the internet it seems to be happening in
so many places at once we're seeing this
unholy it's an oddly unholy alliance
that I've seen the collective
left and then that drives in minutes
exactly what you're saying then you've
got this other day that's just waiting
there for these guys to go to bananas
yeah it's like ah we got all the easy
answers meanwhile you have the Liberals
and everyone all the decent 80% of us
yeah better trying to live unless it's
part of it part of it really comes down
to this there's a weird a sociological
cultural contradiction at the heart of
social democratic leftist ideology on
one hand they they wanted to build
gigantic institutions that are
redistributed Tory and we're supposed to
treat each other like a big family and
we're supposed to have this homogeneous
nation-state on the other hand there
celebrating diversity and encouraging
mass emigration and heterogeneous
populations and guess what those don't
really work together so you build
gigantic Institute drag annex states
that presumes sort of that we're all one
family and then you throw in this this
this diverse set of people especially
with the refugee crisis in Europe and
immigration in the United States and
people are looking around going oh these
people have my family I don't even like
these yeah and yet I'm paying for them
and that is a prescription I mean that
that blows up I mean that's a disaster
it's a powder keg and so is the left and
there this core contradiction that they
have between welfare state on one hand
and their celebration and heterogeneous
populations on the other welfare state
and diversity they don't they don't work
and that basically puts us where Germany
sort of is at right now right where they
said okay three million people come on
in now all these people are gonna have
to pay for you we're not going to
integrate you proper I mean this is not
only now you've got to identitarian
movements rising up in Germany and in
Hungary and of course in Russia and of
course the US you know so it all just
kind of follows it's it's inevitable the
left created this I mean if if after
World War two we had just embraced
liberalism by we should have like we
should have we wouldn't be where we are
today
but we have another chance and that's
why you're here and that's why I'm here
we have another chance now to reimburse
liberal liberal theory yeah and to end
to reject the left and don't feel
yourself just because the enemy of your
enemy is is there it doesn't mean that
has to be your friend I mean we really
do need to think of ourselves as kind of
a dissidents from a political culture
that that rally around
freedom and human rights and universal
human rights and and the annulment of
humanity the champion of the common
person the rights of everyone to live
freely with each other to gain value
from each other and to live in peace and
stop thinking of our fellow human beings
has put possible enemies we don't want
to get drafted into this the political
world that Carl Schmitt imagined for us
as I was describing cross my you you see
it happening right that Schmidty in view
to slice and dice the population who do
you like who do you hate you know who
are your people it's this is not a good
life yeah and we feel like chopping away
at both sides right yeah we do we feel
it and so we don't I just don't feel
like we have to be part of it I mean as
best we can
let's find things we love you know I go
places we love me with people we love of
all different backgrounds all different
kind of cultures learn about alternative
religions learn about new ways to do
things travel right and the age of
liberalism there were no such things as
passports you know all right so let's
let's spend the last portion here on
just these last five years really here
in America because I remember just even
doesn't have to be the last five years
but let's say even three years ago just
it's sort of the emergence of Trump as a
candidate when people started saying the
phrase alright yeah and I did a bunch of
videos on it where I was basically
saying I see two strains to this thing
and people are now using this video
against me and what I saw was there was
the sort of fun me makers and be I know
all of the people who were having fun
online doing often doing awful things
and not see imagery just to upset people
in power and whatever but sometimes very
fun things to and funny things but I saw
it like just the real sort of [ __ ]
posters as they're known and the Peppe
people the whole idea was we could get
we could start sending a frog to some
like intellectual and they're gonna
think that's a racist thing and then
they would say I'm being under attack
from racist they would actually give
them exactly what they wanted so I saw
this this sort of fun [ __ ] posting
whatever part of it not to say it didn't
have elements I didn't like but there
were I saw that as the
and then alongside of that was this
they're talking about in identitarian
part the true racist part the part that
had been sort of underground for a long
time and then because of social media
now is finding that it could actually
Harlan's people and bbl okay so those
and now and you know and I think the
media really fueled both of those things
because basically when Hillary said that
deplorable comment she just lumped the
whole damn thing together and I think if
she had not said that but I think it's
very possible she'd be present oh and
she helped the cause she almost made
they all right exist yeah so was what my
question really is how would you just
define the alright flat-out if I asked
you right now because I think the
definition has changed and how's it but
if I ask you right now in the summer of
2018
yeah the definition it's a you know the
the the phrase all right comes about
what ten years ago I think it was
claimed by Paul Godfrey who himself as a
fellow of cosmic I I would rather look
at this as a writer galleon collectivist
movement you know and in general that
stretches from the early nineteenth
century all the way up to the present
that's the was characterized by a love
of dictatorship a love of power
protectionist trade policy nativist
immigration policy and and and a
resentment against commercial life
because it's because it's it's it's too
heterogeneous into it and nobly if
humanity I mean that to me the alt-right
is one species I guess you could say one
flavoring one instantiation of a much
larger problem that stretches way back
which is an illiberal theory of of life
a liberal theory of politics so that's I
think the right way to think about it
when first time I heard Trump speak was
July 2015 and and I don't even think we
were using the term all right at the
time but he opened his speech with the
immigrants are a problem I thought well
then it was protected therefore its
protections will be protections under
that a third big point was I can fix
everything contract this is all sounded
strangely familiar to me
you know that's that's like the three
pillars of right Hegelian ideology
essentially
and I realized we had a problem and I
understand I do why people had a high
regard for him he was gonna save us from
from the problems that Obama had created
and God knows those problems and and the
left has gotten just bonkers right so we
need we need protection from that but he
introduced his own form of problems and
he unleashed its own form of dangers and
potential potentially very despotic
arrangements of power and in some ways
are more insidious because they appealed
to boo drazi the left has always been a
little bit culturally estranged you know
from the mainstream of American life
with Trump connects very closely with it
this is why fascist movements have been
often times much more successful than
the left socialist ones wait I gotta I
gotta get this because I would have
thought the opposite so if you if you
would have asked me before you said that
I would say the left is the one that has
understood the the culture part of this
at least in the American piece is
certainly academia and culture what what
you could and couldn't joke about
culture yeah the left is as Hayek said
you know I mean socialist ideology never
came from below it's never a working
man's philosophy it was always an
intellectual it was a top-down rule
there's always the ruling class that
hatch so socialist ideology that never
would have been communism socialism all
these things without the intellectual
class but fascism if you'll allow me to
use that term kind of flips a narrative
a little bit it's more it's much more of
a from below if you can keep your
religion you can keep your nation of
your identity your race your language
rally around your friends your family
you know all the things that you believe
are true you and and and and and and
within me as a person as a leader I will
embody all your values and and
collectivise us in a way that that means
something important that that connects
with who you are so in that sense it's
it's a very effective way of being a
liberal all right so all that said what
is our way out of this precarious
position I I think I get where yeah I
get the theme
what you're doing here I love is we have
to just keep fighting for what we've
been saved and also be better well so
Dave I think we need to rethink who we
are I think we need to deepen and enrich
our understanding of who we are and what
we're here to do and it goes back
centuries I mean it was the liberalism
that dogus out of feudalism that ended
the Guild's that brought us free trade
that ended slavery that really gave
birth in modern world and we need to
learn to take credit for that and make
that ethos our ethos go back and read
the works of Adam Smith and the great
Scot Scottish enlightenment thinkers you
know and and understand our history so
we understand ourselves better I think
this is important because we need to
stop thinking of ourselves even though
we are radicals I think you are I think
I am well I almost believe that we
should stop thinking of ourselves that
way we should think of ourselves as
normal if I'm a radical than the phrase
radical it's definitely not as cool as
it used to mean I think I'm open to
these ideas and I I guess being being
open right now and being really living
up to the ideals that you've set forth
here is radical these days it kind of is
and maybe liberalism has always been a
radical Creed because it opposes power
it always has been opposed to power
that's what we have to do now but we
also have to celebrate regular life you
know we have to we have to celebrate the
good life and the beautiful things and
the things we love the people we love
and the choices that we can make and the
technologies we can use a night I fell
in love with the new technology every
single day I came over there I came over
to see you with this new funny pillow
that I bought for $10 on Amazon it
allows me to sleep sitting stayed up I'm
in raptured yeah I think this is the way
their happiness and I think ultimately
is the path to political victory for us
to to be to be more hopeful to be more
cheerful to be more to celebrate life
and celebrate love and celebrate wealth
in a way in which neither the left or
the right are doing right now it gives
us as an opening to be awesome to
emancipate the world we can do this I
got nothing better to do
for more on jeffrey follow them on
twitter jeffrey a tucker
[Music]